[Música]
y lo primero que les quiero contar y
está correlacionado con toda la
discusión que tuvimos antes es que el
problema no es la tecnología el problema
somos nosotros porque antropológicamente
no nacimos para que una generación más
chica nos enseñe a nosotros y ahí está
la primera problemática entonces estamos
el ministerio de educación son todo
viejo estos son todo bien claro no están
entendiendo la problemática es esa que
antropológicamente los comportamientos
se modificaron y todos los que estamos
acá somos los que tenemos el problema no
nuestros hijos o la generación centenial
o centennial ceo late things
y les quiero contar una pequeña anécdota
para darle introducción y es hace cuatro
años atrás le digo a mis hijos que hoy
tienen 17 y 14 pero en esa época tenían
15 y 13 que voy a llevarlos a barcelona
los voy a llevar a madrid y vi un
entusiasmo desaforada yo dije que que
les pasa a estos pibes claro en madrid
era la mayor concentración de pokemones
del mundo entonces los pibes estaban
desaforados por ir ahí no era madrid era
ese juego ese juego que hacía 10 años
estaba muerto y de repente uno ve en
comportamientos así cazando pokemones si
entonces el engagement que todo el mundo
habla y nadie sabe lo que es porque en
realidad dos de iu sencillos también del
engagement con este equipo con esta cosa
no se sabe lo que es
todo el mundo tiene data pero la data
conectada al negocio y tomar decisiones
en realtime no lo está pudiendo hacer
nadie acá
estoy hablando de realtime no estoy
hablando de pedirle permiso al papá y
que vaya que vuelva y que después a
bueno los de compliance me dieron una
razón para que cambie la coma que
entonces esto usted estoy hablando de
que la data realmente usada para
conectar el negocio todos tenemos
reservorio de datos todos hablamos de
big data pero realmente usarla para la
ejecución del negocio hoy en colombia no
lo estamos pudiendo lograr
principalmente por los aspectos
regulatorios en principio sí entonces es
todo el mundo está diciendo que las
datas el rey cierto todo el mundo se
pagarán big small medium cual event data
pero el problema es que el tema no es la
data el tema es la conexión humana la
antropología del comportamiento nos dice
que los seres humanos conectamos y es la
conexión lo que deberíamos medir no el
engagement a ver si me quiere no me
quiere si me pone re cuadritos o lo que
fuera
y la conexión humanamente es emoción
somos seres emocionales el 81% de las
decisiones que tomamos al día sin
importar que los varones me hagan a
media semana sí que dice esta vieja son
emocionales y la mayoría son
inconscientes porque tienen que ver con
todos nuestros registros de donde
crecimos y donde nos movimos bueno y la
emoción es interacción si no hay
interacción entre dos personas no hay
emoción si no importa si es con sofía al
robot o con quién es pero hay
interacción entonces esa interacción es
la que tenemos que medir qué difícil que
este y la interacción es una relación
porque porque si la llevamos a un eje de
tiempo si es una relación y podemos
medir interacciones la tecnología hoy
hoy yo puedo aprender mi gran y porque
me dice que estoy corriendo menos que
ayer porque tiene el dato de ayer si no
tuviera esa relación no me podría decir
que yo esté corriendo menos el minuto
por kilómetro y la relación en realidad
es engagement les di cuatro elementos
para medir el engagement
o sea que cuando te ponen engagement de
una de 10 10 hay que medir cada uno de
estos elementos porque somos seres
humanos y las conexiones no son las
mismas no es lo mismo un argentino que
un colombiano que un peruano que un
ecuatoriano sí y los datos no venden los
productos en realidad los productos es
lo que nos hacen sentir y hoy lo que
estamos viendo es el sentimiento pero lo
estamos haciendo de una manera que
parece muy cuantitativa pero el año
pasado vino acá un gurú que es martín
lynch trump que tiene una infinidad de
libros y me dijo paula la segmentación
del futuro es emocional lo que pasa que
todavía las empresas no lo pueden no lo
pueden articular ni lo pueden ejecutar
pero la próxima generación de
segmentación que ahora le pusieron el
nombre fashion de perfilación es
emocional si es perfiles ya no es
cuántos años tienen donde vivir si son
mujer o híbrido o lo que fuera o dónde
compras dónde llevas a tus hijos si no
es el perfil es hoy la tecnología es un
facilitador de que te permite ver
patrones de comportamiento y a partir de
ciertos algoritmos te puede
predecir ciertos tipos de comportamiento
y este es un char que diseñó esta vieja
de qué está hablando el mundo del futuro
de las empresas son plataformas y en
latinoamérica nos cuesta mucho hacer
partnership y todo el mundo está
contratando tecnología propietaria y
gasta millones creyendo que va a ser el
segundo amazon el tercer a amazon y en
realidad los modelos del futuro al o
amazon son aquellas empresas que pueden
detectar talentos en terceros y armar
ceiling de muchas empresas hoy el mundo
de la belleza yo puedo bajar una
aplicación de l'oréal y puedo ver en
tiempo real el pelo como me queda
entonces eso es una experiencia que
después favorece que yo me vaya a
comprar l'oréal 6.1 de la tintura de
pelo y esto es lo que las empresas no
están entendiendo hoy el modelo es
construyó lo que hoy llaman fashion
mínimo producto viable cuando lo tengo
al cien por ciento construyó un servicio
sobre esos de valor añadido y el tercero
es experiencias muchas empresas se
olvidan de eso y lo trabajan en
unidades están casa entonces si yo
compro un tiquete habían para no poner
marcas cuál es el mismo producto viable
que por lo que pagó salga a tiempo y
queme en el asiento que quiero es cierto
entonces para que me dan un bip vino que
es el tercer nivel de experiencias si no
tengo el mínimo producto viable entonces
todo este concepto lo que hay que ver es
que hoy estamos construyendo plataformas
y la experiencia completa a la gente no
dice ay esto me lo dio una agencia esto
me lo dio el gerente de marketing de la
empresa tal esto la gente no hace esto
esa razón sino la gente vive una
experiencia de manera holística pues lo
que tenemos que asegurar es que la
plataforma esté completa y que la
experiencia del consumidor no importa si
hay 20 empresas sede bien sí
y eso significa nuestro comportamiento
cuando salió el kindle todas dijeron no
se va a leer más en papel claro que sí
amazon tiene una biblioteca física una
librería física en mayor porque porque
hoy mañana y siempre va a depender de
las preferencias del consumidor
mi papá seguramente va a tener un
inodoro que le lea los electrolitos
porque tiene diabetes tipo 4 yo no tengo
diabetes no voy a necesitar es inodoro
pero yo si corro maratones entonces yo
sí voy a necesitar night land entonces
dicen unos 100 o 0 no va a haber de todo
y para todos como fue en nuestra
historia de la humanidad pero si la
tecnología está cambiando patrones de
comportamiento y el principal es la
democratización del conocimiento si
cuando este señor inventó esto ustedes
creen que fue un invento tecnológico
claro que no resolvió un problema él
quería buscar una canción en 5000 es
antropología del comportamiento el que
entienda la antropología del
comportamiento va a estar un paso
adelante la tecnología lo que hace es un
facilitador de un cambio de
comportamiento para mejor
nuestra calidad de vida todo esto va a
pasar cuando me siento con la gente me
dicen no en colombia falta un montón
pavo falta un montón pero va a pasar hoy
se venden un montón de dispositivos en
el mundo que probablemente acá en
latinoamérica todavía no se adopten de
manera así exponencial pero si van a
llegar ya mi hijo en un colegio de acá
estudia con aumento reality hoy acá acá
en colombia ok y yo lo vi y me quedé así
como diciendo ay porque los viejos que
hacemos ahí ya lo vi es mentira que lo
vi la primera vez que lo veía entonces
nosotros somos los que tenemos el
problema este dispositivo este
dispositivo es un sensor que ya se usa
en europa es el reemplazo del iphone
pero hecho holístico arriba o sea es
como minority report es una pantalla que
se refleja ahí y todo va a estar de
sensor esto va a ser una interacción
porque cada cosa que nos mejore la
calidad de vida el ser humano no va a
adoptar sí
y estamos en el negocio de las emociones
o de la data que este es la reflexión
que yo les quiero dejar yo creo que
estamos en la en la reflexión la
reflexión más importante es que estamos
en el negocio de la data pero en
realidad es la emoción lo que nos
conecta y en la medida que entendamos
las emociones de lo que produce cada
categoría en las que nosotros trabajamos
es lo que va a mejorar eso
esto es importante yo trabajé en disney
en cocacola y en la época que trabajé en
las dos compañías y viví en seis países
eran las marcas más amadas del mundo a
mí me da un orgullo cuando me cambié de
cocacola a mastercard dijeron ah pero
esas empresas y entrevisté con muchas
compañías de tecnologías mejorar estas
empresas no son a peeling para nosotros
porque eso es cualquier cosa o sea eso
ya ya no está bueno en marketing siete
de las primeras diez top brands hoy son
de tecnología yo no pensaría pero como
no estás midiendo el amor que el amor es
emocional y la tecnología es como más
racional el tema es que la tecnología
hoy
aparte de que te resuelve muchos
problemas en la vida y vos llegás a amar
eso porque la gente elige uno ver por
qué religión o spotify porque elige un
ways no es porque ame la marca así pero
si te resuelve una parte de tu vida ese
como y forma parte de tu estilo de vida
pues ya al incorporar porque te resuelve
un problema entonces esto es súper
importante las marcas también
encontraron nuevos retadores
si no me agarraron con caracoles no te
preocupes
amazon es un nuevo retador todo el mundo
está mirando a amazon porque amazon es
una compañía que tiene ese
comportamiento de contratar partnerships
y ellos trabajan con un concepto de
llama prosumer ya no consumen prosumer
son los pioneros que te adoptan una
tecnología y los prueban llame a que los
van probando de acuerdo al tracking de
comportamiento lo que van haciendo es
midiendo eso un tema corto sobre esto se
acuerdan el año 28 que nos clavó el
teléfono y todo el mundo entró en un
tema como de la droga viste hoy que hago
que no tengo teléfono porque no me bajan
o me bajan o me baja mi hijo una semana
después me llama el más grande y me dice
ay no sabes la gente de apple me mandó
para ser embajador ley esos mentirosos
un virus eso bájalo eso nada esos chau
eso es un engaño y resulta que lo habían
elegido para probar bajar los años antes
de masificarlo y le daban
con beneficios en itunes le abandonaré
tetera etcétera entonces a la tecnología
le perdonas que se equivoque siempre y
cuando siempre y cuando después lo
puedan arreglar no pero a las compañías
de consumación no le dan ese permiso si
ha sido te equivocas con un yogurt te
equivocaste se acabó entonces es
interesante porque la economía te p la
tecnología te permite probar cosas
diferentes
con estos próximas ya se puede la la
tecnología 3d ya puede hacer autos ya
puede hacer comida ya pueda hacer ropa
yo sé todavía en colombiano llegó pero
hoy si las las tenis las zapatillas te
las puedes personalizar entonces este
tipo de cosas va a llegar porque la
personalización va a ser dentro de cinco
años una parte trascendental en todas
las categorías
este concepto de usher es muy
interesante porque empresas como amazon
lo que han logrado es llevar el paz de
user experience que es el mismo producto
viable customer experience que es la
relación entre esa funcionalidad cuando
la tenés al cien y amazon alibaba que
llegan al human experience miren el
nombre que le pusieron human experience
you ex que todavía en latinoamérica
tenemos muchos gaps después de que
tenemos bien el ibex pasas al castro me
vex que es la interrelación y después
que tenemos muy bien eso llegas al human
experience como es a alexa o como es
otro de estos proyectos sí y la
cartelización y esto es súper importante
nos da contar una pequeña anécdota una
amiga mía de llamada karina quessep me
regaló un médico en una conferencia que
doy una alexa eco y la puse en mi casa
como era en inglés dije no nos va a
venir la casa no va a pasar nada
hoy obviamente hoy no tenemos todas las
licencias conectadas ahí pero los chicos
la usaban para buscar canciones para que
les leyeran libros para que buscaran
cosas en youtube y entonces es uno de
mis hijos el más grande empieza a buscar
canciones y empieza a decir alex en ese
que alexa no sé qué y parece ser que
alexa no encontraba el tema que él pedía
sí y entonces mi hijo dijo una mala
palabra y alexa le dijo no hace falta
que digas más las palabras que hago y yo
uat está kretina no me va a mí
reemplazar porque es lo primero que
pensé no pensé que la tecnología me
ayudaba a buscar una canción pensé no me
puede reemplazar esta kretina y me quedé
como dije bueno pensaba las piensas que
tienes que decir algo inteligente bueno
parece que después álex encontró la
canción después de media hora y mi hijo
le dijo ay alexa te amo y alexa le
contestó yo también onesource sweet
dije si yo me pillo con alexa vamos a
tener un problema entonces por eso le
digo que el problema los tenemos
nosotros eso vino para quedarse no es
como otras cosas que hizo péndulo en la
sociedad posmoderna y va a ir para atrás
eso vino para quedarse ahora uno va
elegir si quiere álex en su casa y para
que la quiere y en que lo va a usar
entonces para estas cosas álex a mi no
me gusta ni un poco pero para que me
despierte me haga me diga en qué momento
tengo que salir y que sea mi asistente
personal en una vida que yo llevo me
parece que está muy bien entonces lo que
les quiero decir es que la tecnología no
nos va a arruinar la vida eso depende
del tipo de preferencias y de que haga
en tu vida y esto es súper importante
las empresas que no incorporen la
tecnología transversalmente a cualquier
modelo de negocio se van a quedar afuera
del mercado porque porque la gente hoy
tiene un hoy tenemos todos un tipo de
vida que todo lo que nos permita vivir
es algo que se hace el hombre de la
montaña y te vayas a vivir a cosechar
arándanos sí si vivimos en una ciudad
todo lo que puedas mejorar
adaptar rápido y la inteligencia
artificial que hay mostrado en el robot
sofía si la inteligencia artificial te
permite predecir cosas y mejorar te
también la calidad de vida porque en
nike a mi me tira como tengo que mejorar
eso con una altura de tanto con una
carretera de tanto entonces todo lo que
te pueda mejorar la vida lo vas a
adoptar los chicos mis hijos ya nacieron
nativos digitales entonces yo ya lo
tienen incorporado ni siquiera tienen
miedo de poner una tarjeta de crédito
para el playstation nosotros decimos
claro con la clave no sacaremos ok pero
ellos no tienen un problema así mamá te
va a llegar con perú y así te dicen cómo
y pues como sabes que perú entonces
ellos ya no tienen conflicto con eso
porque para ellos ya nacieron en ese
sistema somos nosotros los que tenemos
que adaptarnos a ellos entonces va a
haber procesamiento de datos masivos va
a ver muchos trabajos que hoy dentro de
cinco años no van a existir pero hay
14.000 casas nuevas que nacieron
entonces las problemáticas de abogados
administradores etcétera etcétera y si
el mundo va a cambiar y vas a ser tal
vez especialista si quieres ser
especialista generalista si querés es
generalista el tema de la educación va a
cambiar mucho en los próximos años sí y
las tecnologías disruptivas te cambian
patrones de conducta lo que pasa que el
ser humano tarda mucho en darse cuenta
porque tiene que pasar mucho tiempo
usted se ve hace 15 años atrás o 10 años
de atrás y ustedes si se levantan sus
abuelos y hablan con sus abuelos le
dirían que estarían así
le dirían que en vez de decirle a tu
novio a tu esposo a tu amante ay mi amor
te amo te extraño con locura le mandas
un corazón y ya está
mi abuela se muere si le cuento eso
entonces todo este mundo se va a
acelerar porque los siglos de tecnología
van a ser todo lo que es block change va
a democratizar muchísimo todo lo que es
la tecnología del conocimiento y los
pagos y las conversaciones muy rápido
porque si no van a matar la interacción
va a ser entre conversaciones si te voy
a mostrar el modelo que para mí es el
modelo más importante sí que es sin
importar el final si siempre vamos a
estar conectados y en realidad el
engagement es esto el engagement tiene
una mejora de la experiencia porque al
final del día somos seres experiencia
les aprendemos con los cinco sentidos no
hay otra forma de aprender para el ser
humano no importa si son nuestros hijos
son nosotros primero descriptivo después
comparativos y eventualmente si son muy
inteligentes conceptual entonces
aprendemos por experiencias y aprendemos
por opuestos y por ver y por tocar y por
oír segundo tenés que ser rápido porque
porque en la época de mi abuela tenía
una heladera que le duraba 30 años y que
la tenía que cerrar
con taekwondo ok pero hoy si se te rompe
la nevera sí que hay es la cambiada
entonces tienes que ser rápido porque
los ciclos de innovación hoy son más
rápidos sobre todo en la categoría de
tecnología tenéis que ser el cambio
tienes que promover el cambio y por eso
ahora se pusieron de moda antes eran los
pilotos ahora se llaman betas pero ello
mismo es agarrar un micro mercado un
micro segmento tener las variables
controlables y probar sobre esas
variables y sobre esas variables ver y
arreglarlo rápido y volver a construir
hoy la tecnología tenga la capacidad de
escuchar cuando yo empecé marketing si
subíamos las ventas yo decía es que la
publicidad que dice soy una chimba
pero no tenía forma de probarlo entonces
decía seguramente la publicidad que dice
si yo de estas marcas las manejos súper
bien pero hoy si tiene forma de
mostrarlo porque hoy la tecnología te
lleva a un nivel de performance
casi al 100% hoy sabes si es la
publicidad si es el producto que es
cuarto el perdón quinto
las empresas que no nos ayuden a las
comunidades que están operando y siempre
lo hablamos con mauricio eso en el largo
plazo se van a morir porque porque hoy
los estados no tienen la capacidad de
arreglar todos los problemas entonces
eso se llama yerbal y antes se llamaba
responsabilidad social y lo evolucionó
michael porter ayer valió que lo tenés
que tener dentro de tu modelo de negocio
si vos hoy no tenés una compañía que en
huelva wing good estás muerto estás
muerto porque las nuevas generaciones
son muy críticas de eso mis hijos cuando
yo llego a casa me dice por qué no tiras
en el cesto de basura que corresponde si
vos me arruinaste el planeta yo no te
arruine el plan bien y ahí empezaron una
discusión entonces los chiquitos son
mucho más y el tercero es fíjense que la
marca va al final
si uno hace todo esto bien el engagement
es nulo la marca se construye sola si
vos haces estos cinco parámetros bien y
entonces para terminar para que mauricio
no me mate si es la nueva realidad
depende de la consistencia de estos seis
elementos que digo y adicionalmente si
los puntos de acción para la
construcción de una ley bueno perdone si
devuelve algo se introspectivo crea un
segundo acto antes las compañías eran
muy egocéntricas entonces tenés que
devolverle algo a la persona no importa
en la categoría que estés trabajando si
te fue más e introspectivo pregúntate
realmente porque te están eligiendo sí y
eso a partir de eso puedes construir
cosas de ser value y después si te fue
mal crea un segundo acto si somos seres
experiencial es y si a la tecnología le
permitimos equivocarse entonces crea un
segundo acto y hacerlo bien no porque no
sé si te han tercer acto
y en resumen
si un producto no está pensado en
nosotros sino en quien vas a estar y en
eso es algo que quieran compartir a
ustedes en facebook en instagram en
cualquiera de estas redes sociales
comparten cualquier cosa lo que
compartís en cuanto se comparte en el
mundo hoy de todo lo que hay navegando
en contenido sólo el 16 por ciento saben
por qué porque no es relevante para vos
porque vos no te vas a exponer ahí y
facebook se llama face porque vos ponés
to face ok luego no vas a compartir algo
entonces imagínate algo que quieran
compartir sí y que no quieras dejar de
usar sí y que adicionalmente haga el
bien no adicción en el mal sentido de la
palabra sino en el mejor sentido de la
palabra
y esos engagement gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]